oh there you go
check check check can you hear us oh my
god where we at 15 minutes
oh it's definitely tay's fault three
fingers for tay always blame too tastes
great also uh we see our lower thirds
here are different uh you know what
we're just gonna brush all past this uh
hi welcome thank you guys for
waiting and sticking around uh my name's
rob
and this is peter hi hi uh again thank
you guys for hanging around but we're
gonna uh we're gonna tackle this uh
we're playing breath of the wild this is
triforce and uh peter why don't you
explain what you were saying earlier uh
yeah what you couldn't hear earlier was
me saying that this is probably gonna be
the last episode of triforce at least
for a while uh we're seeing a lot you
know the community do amazing things
with this game and we're kind of running
out of ideas with all this great stuff
already out there so um yeah for now
we're gonna call it you know an end for
triforce unless something amazing
crosses our minds down the road uh but
for this last episode we're gonna try to
speed run the game
and we will have no problems whatsoever
it'll go perfectly and we'll probably
break the record
i'm joking
yeah i watched uh
a bunch of videos yeah um you know
trying to get the uh the know know-how
the tricks the tips and some of these
things there's not
well we'll do it we'll do it all um but
enough of us chatting
let's get right to it peter started i'm
gonna be playing uh for the first
stretch until uh i decide to uh end my
life if it gets too difficult
but uh for now um yeah peter's be
following along um
some of the uh
speed running uh
you know videos on youtube uh
i have not i did not set up a timer but
we could uh we could just roughly yeah
assume so we're at uh 11 17. we'll call
it there and uh
let's do it
so the things that are going to be very
tricky for us to keep up with the speed
run include
taking advantage of certain like
animations that might absolve you from
getting hurt when jumping off of a tower
i don't know if we're gonna be able to
pull it off um we also need to find uh
some some beetles in the wild those
things are fast they they know how to
get away quick but they're key to
getting uh
to even having a fighting chance at the
last boss but on that note we should
also state huge spoilers assuming we
make it there yeah if you haven't beaten
the game you don't want to be spoiled on
the ending at some point you may want to
tune out because we are going to try to
beat the game
uh again try being the key word try try
force try try
uh
yeah it's a bladed rhino so in the video
uh the the gentleman who uh
i think has the record now for 41.25
okay 41 minutes uh i i was watching on
the bus this morning and like a little
bit last night i did not see
when and where he picks up a bladed
rhino i believe beetle uh rhino beetle
uh
i don't know where that is wait but you
were saying he did amiibo stuff could it
have fallen from an amiibo and also are
we screwing ourselves we didn't get any
ammunitions grab our amiibos already
already i mean
yeah yay is this my first time against
gannon you know i uh
trying to skip this i i have beaten
gammon ganon um
and i did it probably too late because i
blew right through them um but this is
going to be the exact opposite
uh i wish i tackled him earlier yeah
i'm trying to skip i should be able to
skip this yeah
is that a settings feature
uh i don't know
it's all right
that's a great question i don't have an
answer for you too bad let's deal with
it
yeah yeah some maybe maybe eric can get
us amiibos eric if uh you're watching
god bless you for helping the stream uh
actually get on its
feet but uh
we need i believe we need an epona
amiibo and then
any other amiibo that's gonna bring us
some hot loot
we need it
so far i can't skip any of this i i
guess that's a settings
thing rob why is the legend in german
oh yeah i saw that um
one of these when these guys uh these uh
speedrunners said that um the dialogue
is much faster in german i'm also pretty
perfect already uh i'm excited to
actually see this in germany i took uh
two years of german no
none of it
lost a lot tight
this is
it's really bad because all i want to do
is is read this back in a really mocking
voice yeah but i have no
oh i see the german it's german because
it um scrolls faster so yeah i'm i'm
excited to see what you guys have in the
uh chat um very fascinated by like all
the techniques these guys are doing so
if you have any tips or anything like
that let me let us know gadge comes
through with the amiibos gadge has every
zelda
wow
we got them all thank you gadget i think
we'll be fine i'm already losing time
so
close who needs them
i'm trying to do that stupid trick
oh man
again if you're just joining us we're
gonna legit speed run this
this is a record run right this and also
you know what and i think about it i i
was thinking that last night i want to
do a run where we don't skip any of the
cutscenes
i don't think anyone's done that um so
we could what do you call that the cut
scene run
yeah okay story percent mode
no timer no timer yeah that's that was a
mistake
to begin
people are going to keep asking why this
is not in english so we will continue to
tell you because apparently it makes the
game faster if you play it specifically
in german
and because we're trying to speed run
that's that's the goal
i can't even do this move oh the oh the
like
infinite run thing yeah
it's weird
you know it's funny watching uh this guy
do it was i was like
i could probably pull this off
i like
seriously was thinking i could i could
actually maybe like i mean get through
like the shrines yeah i can't even get
out the door is he playing on wii u
yeah that's another thing i found i
heard was that uh loading times are much
quicker with uh wii u the more you know
the more you know
oh boy
current time three minutes
making sick time says goop 38 minutes
left i mean so far we are basically on
par with him
i mean
go sorry i was reading the chat
okay i'm getting it
oh wait he did this all right i'm gonna
make up last time right here blow past
that dude
don't worry about him
get that axe
all right now i got it oh my god this is
so difficult
stop don't don't look at me like i'm an
idiot because i am my wife i guess
that's fine
okay so he just goes straight to the
tower right uh yes you should well i
guess you can't see the beacon yet but
yeah okay he drops down this cliff go
around these buildings
yes yes
this is going to be great don't worry
this will get interesting
oh okay
link
we're totally up to snuff right now
didn't he have bugs by now
josh what the hell
did he have bugs did i miss the bug
already
dude that's the one thing i'm scared of
is like i we have to get that bug
i know well we do have amiibos right so
worst case scenario crap do they drop
uh i don't know okay i don't even know
how to do the like how do you don't run
in don't run into these guys you're
gonna get in trouble
i don't even know how he holds the
controller
[Laughter]
i got it i don't know but i like
watching you do it where is hold on hold
on so the shield oh is the shield up on
the mountain
yeah okay the shield is back up here so
you gotta turn around it's okay it's
okay
you got me looking at your where up here
i think it's back this way
oh great
we can go back oh here it is we'll go
back well that's the shrine yeah we'll
go i i yeah i i know we're doing i got
this
okay so he runs up to the bokoblin oh he
hit okay you gotta get from that
bokoblin that's right outside the
entrance
oh he knocks the shield off of him
duh
well now we're going to be in the air
yeah
oh boy we got more people saying no
sound no sound for the game
you guys trolling us because we you did
have okay cool all right
i missed the bug
bummer
that's okay
i mean i'm
i mean are we gonna is there a hard stop
on this
are we calling it at a certain time or
are we actually gonna like
stick with this
dude there's no way
we'll be here all day
i mean we'll go we'll go to we'll go to
12 45 12 45. we'll see how far we get
okay and you know what maybe we'll maybe
this will
transform into like a
can we even beat this game
uh
with just four shrines
if people in check can let me know i is
there must be a settings option to skip
all that right
because i'm not even seeing the like
prompt
might have to go into your inventory and
then over to the system menu
should i just do that
i suppose yeah i know i know bugs don't
drop from amiibos i'm hoping we can at
least
get anything of value from them i'm
gonna try to change the settings we know
we're screwed it's okay
i mean this is this is a new record for
me
yeah that's true yeah i still haven't
tried to do this on my own what you
think maybe we should have done x then
plus
so no that's the uh how to sprint
gonna do the run
oh no no i see what you're saying what
excellent oh you hit x then it brings up
a dialogue to skip but maybe you can't
skip everything i'm not like no but he's
oh there it is
thank you very much
beep
okay so this move this is immediately
the first thing that that's super
difficult okay so rob has to jump off in
a swing i don't have a shield off okay
you can't do it then it's not gonna work
let's see
[Laughter]
whoa
no you didn't do it i thought you did it
for a second
hey you're a little far ahead
no worries we'll get the shield after we
said
it'll be fine we thought
i almost looked like it froze for a
second
i guess we'll have to take the slow way
down
right
that'll cost us but i have a couple
tricks of my own
is it just jumping off again because i'm
pretty sure that's not gonna work
uh
no right we can't i don't have the
shield
oh dude oh we're making back so much
time
what
all right so that poke goblin's gonna be
yeah where is that so watch out for
those
the two
oh yeah okay
see
i should be oh no maybe i can't escape i
think there's something that you can't
get this is actually not really a
cutscene is it
joey says this is going swimmingly
i picked
there we go your support means
everything
we got this uh so what okay i'll go for
the bokoblin yes uh
oh so you know what we at some point
have to uh
fast travel back to the uh resurrection
okay so then maybe we get the uh bladed
uh rhino beetle there if you guys in uh
chat wanna let me know exactly where it
is i don't know i can skip this maybe
um
that'd be great
because we're in this together aren't we
it's a team effort can i pick the
see a lot of the problem with uh german
is i don't know uh
what dialogue options
do any of these guys
have uh
i would maybe go back and fight those
two i feel like but they didn't have a
shield for sure yeah i didn't see it
okay they're just archers okay
well okay we really only needed that
momentarily right
sure to get off the tower yeah i was
thinking about that uh we don't need it
maybe we're just gonna beat this guy's
time because we're not so obsessed with
getting a shield
that's a real good point
reset no we're not going to resize we
got this one there are a couple tricks i
got to make up some time i keep saying
that i'm not i don't know what he's
talking about
i feel like at some point you're just
going to play a video of the speedrun
and say yeah we're doing it
all right
so
for anyone joining us we are doing a
speedrun of breath of the wild or at
least trying to
uh
because this is the last episode of
triforce for now
it's been fun but we're going to take a
break for a few weeks yes something cool
crosses our minds sure and you know we
got dlc down the road we'll be back oh
yeah for sure um
so
we are following along with the fastest
speed run on youtube and trying to keep
up with that oh i gotta get in first and
if you're wondering we're playing in
german because it makes the game faster
uh scrolls faster or something yeah yeah
and we really need those precious
seconds to make a difference
we'll make it back i wonder where he's
would be at right now because time wise
man i don't know why 13 minutes in i
don't know why i didn't time this damn
oh i can get that maybe
13 minutes in he's just finishing up the
shrine
oh we're not that far back
keep rocking baby
zelda will be there in a jiff
oh i blew that
that's cool
later
i'm saving zelda
god
how did he make that jump he used the
magnesis to move no he didn't he made
the joke oh yeah he actually how did he
do it oh now i got this [ __ ]
what am i doing that was a wrong move
ah nice shot jerk all right i'm gonna do
it this time do you remember how to do
it
sure
nope we're gonna have to do it the uh
long way oh because you need the shield
he damn it yeah but i actually think he
didn't even use the shield that shield
trick i don't even think he used it
there
oh my god this jerk
you can just grab the door from there or
does your magnesis not reach that far no
i'm sure just do this
oh yeah interesting
interesting
i learned that from another speedrunner
you actually it tricks the game into
creating a parallel universe where
you're actually four minutes faster
time
oh that was an ace jump
he i know he shield jumps but i'm pretty
sure he doesn't do it there but i could
be completely wrong i mean he does it
there
he did yeah yeah i thought you were
saying that he just didn't need that
boost but yeah that's what he did i
thought he didn't do it there well that
big difference
nope
nope yep
yep why
flawless
flawless run
[Laughter]
oh this is fun i love how the two
regulars are giving us different
feedback here you know uh if you
actually hit five of these you get it's
uh six seconds back tight all right we
should be good i think i got it back
your groove
and what i wonder if that would actually
slow down the loading time if you hit
that
you know
these are the questions we all we'll ask
ourselves forget it okay next
all right so i got no time for you old
man
also you're pretty big for that
paraglider i'm nimble
sir are you fat shaming him no
actually he is technically a
real buff guy well no he's technically a
ghost ghost
that's why
the lore checks out
no
yes
okay so then he starts casting amiibo
[Music]
i don't know what once he's using but
he's getting a lot of fish
okay
uh oh but he's not getting all of them
that's weird and he's missing the
treasure chests that come he picked up
like two fish out of the ten that
dropped no i didn't mean to do that
[Laughter]
uh should we try an amiibo yeah
probably should have had it selected oh
my god
yeah yeah
nope
uh
instagram yes
verwinden
yeah yeah
the against
hold on
you can't do it there let's give me the
x
vise
doesn't want it
i've actually don't think i've ever done
an amiibo
are you
what the f
why would it let us do it
oh it's probably a setting i had i have
to like
the amiibo only works because if you
have a account log then
hooray
forget it
we're gonna do the run with we don't
need no snake enemies we just decided
that we're going to do the run without
the uh amiibos so
we're doing the the legit run so do you
know where you're going right now yes
okay cause you've seen me just be going
this is so difficult to
you should
don't laugh no i like watching you do it
it's really funny
what is the um command to do it
you gotta hold down
whistle i think you have to tap whistle
no you tap uh hey i'm doing it right now
the timing of it is just real tough and
now i can't strain out my view how does
he do that
he must be a wizard
that boy
making time
i'm trying to figure out where you where
you are right now
damn no opponent then
okay
for screw
i could have avoided that but we're
doing the cinematic version
so you know i've been staring at the
camera for like 10 seconds because i
basically saw that [ __ ] going
so good on you
oh god
[Laughter]
we're not even going to make it to
hyrule
oh god
oh god
so
what is this trick here where what wall
does he go up he just jumps
what does he do
i mean he just goes around how does he
climbs the moss
just
don't i don't think that's the
i said
i feel you like
ah
yabashiv
cool
you gotta skip all these peter
gotsta
yeah
are you checking your email
we're in this together bud
ah don't even
all right so is there a trick to getting
through this shrine isn't there like a
he's a weird boulder you've got a no not
this one he's this is just bombs and
he's just throwing this stuff just
throwing it
all right we're making pretty good
progress
we are currently
is there any way uh god damn we should
have started whatever eight minutes
behind um
is uh
go on
is there any way we could like catch up
with our time i don't really know where
we're at hmm if only i knew how to speak
in this game better than the speed
runner
no i mean like we could like
now catch up and account for how how uh
where our time is at i know we started
11 17. oh yeah well i mean we're at like
22 minutes right now
and he is when he finishes the shrine
oh yeah baby when he finishes the shrine
it was just under 14 minutes
although technically there was about a
minute in his video before he started
playing so
yeah we're like 10 minutes behind okay i
know he did yep give it up
nailed it
great grand
i totally just made up like what was
that like three minutes i just got back
no carolyn pettit hi hi carolyn pettit
it's good to see you it's great to see
you i can't see you but rob she doesn't
think there's any way to make up time
but i feel she may be correct
i don't know what they're talking about
but you got some tricks up your sleeve
right yeah man uh
i was into the subreddits last night
oh like the the deep web
and i uh got some cool tricks
that are that are gonna blow your mind
and your socks off would these tricks
apply to the real world are we talking
life hacks
yeah
such as
hearty breakfast
i like it
oh uh now i um
i go back here okay
right
yeah
oh look we're in sync with the youtube
videos
um where
is that damn beetle
this uh do you want me to go back
i don't know i was hoping chad maybe i
missed it uh if you guys know where that
that freaking blade rhino beetle is uh
it's gotta be on a tree right
yeah generally they're on a tree look
for some trees
get yourself a stew going
baby
you got yourself you got yourself a
beetle stew going
it's on a tree yeah thanks josh
which one
god damn it i can't really chat
you know the thing is how is he looking
at chat he's doing it like in
i told you he's a wizard all right
look chat look at chat if they're gonna
tell me as soon as you come out tree
trunk apparently tree chop tree trunk
i think it's i think it's further down
oh here's oh here i'll
here's all save time
see this
that's a that's a cool one
where is it down i don't know no he
didn't go down there yet he ran along so
he ran along this cliff
heading down
yeah yeah
i feel like it's on the tree near the
the oldman the gary oldman
first mushroom tree oh really now we
pass that
the beetle is next to the mushroom
did i scare it
there's nothing to be afraid of
yeah i don't
we
i feel like we have to forge ahead i
don't know
there's a good chance we scared it
let's be honest we need it i know
if we're not gonna we're not gonna do
this i'm gonna even freaking get there
you never know never say never oh where
am i even going uh i gotta go um
this way right did you see that lizard
just staring at you down there
we don't have time for that what uh
uh what's next he thinks he runs this
place and you're just gonna let him
think it i'm waiting for the thing to
reload
all right
what the hell
i don't need to hear that
what is he doing wait just steal
yourself hold on
i'll get these mushrooms
this will help okay so he exits
and i feel like he takes an immediate
left yes he makes an immediate left
that's right
and then he just sort of
manages to
run up the cliff
you mean like this
there you go all right you're doing it
no no no
yeah like oh
yeah yeah
i dig it i like it
look at that look at you
now what
dude i really need a shield uh
so you run past that tree
that away
we're whistling to keep our spirits up
all right okay so you're gonna sort of
hang on the left side of the cliff
look to your left
jeff we need the shield yes
no beetle no shield
you can fly
okay so yeah you need to cross this
bridge snowboard down oh wait we can't i
can't do it
oh we're not going to be able to make it
to that jump
oh no that's fine just move this guy
yep
no don't
yeah living on the edge
uh it's right uh up here right no
so let's see
oh god he moves so fast
okay so he crosses the bridge
much faster than we did peter peter
peter rob
i'm working on it all right so he goes
up he goes it's just that first boulder
that was right in front of him
man he's just
how are you going to survive
so he is a little well i guess you guys
are close
god damn it this is gonna this is great
it's fine this bat is gonna kill me no
no no no don't let it kill you which way
you need to go up you need to go up up
up
so at the top of this little mountain
there's a shrine
peter help me climb club you fool i told
you to get to the top of this thing
specify
that poor cold baby
i don't ha
all right we'll trade off after this
let's do it
rob's annoyed with me no i'm not i'm
actually not he's a horrible liar no i'm
not let me uh did you hear that like the
the lying tone in his voice what what's
going on here i'm sorry
um
so if you're just joining us
we suck at zelda
that's the first status of our attempt
to speed run
uh
i can't i don't have much stamina i'm
scared to jump you got enough to get
there okay
all right good run
this is so hard to skip it's just like
he's like a mile ahead of us like all
i'm
okay
oh we're good
time
uh 16 minutes in
we are keep going oh
[Laughter]
he's 16 minutes in we are
31 minutes in so we are currently
half as fast
but thank you for joining us and
continuing to stick with us
keep going skip that skip that makes a
perfect point we have two people here
we should finish this
in half the time
oh yeah that doesn't work out dude yeah
the math works just divide by two
that's oh that's oh yeah yeah
wow
huh
we got ourselves a fighting chance
golden nut peter golden nugget says
you're so bad at this yes
thank you thank you guys thank you gold
nugget for joining us um
yeah this is dueled what duel no no it's
not like we're using each joy con
that's for another day
uh
if we play the youtube video at 0.5
speed we'll be even within
that's a great line i'm currently
playing at 1.25 so i mean yeah okay so
here you want to yeah you want to cryos
but you need to be so
you forget it
leave me alone i'm doing what i can okay
fast faster oh man you know i want to
for the children nice nice nice nice
[Laughter]
peter
ah
it's fine it's fine it's fine you gotta
cry also that dude i hear you i hear you
i just don't care it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's still so fine
i've never been more fine
hell yeah oh my god
we're reading comments on twitch and
youtube um
siegfried
sick fried that's a way more interesting
name i like that
the whistles go woo-woo
[Laughter]
from bubrub
it's like an alarm clock
you're supposed to be making breakfast
by then
i don't know what you're talking about
never seen that famous video i think was
out in oakland here about the um keep
going
about the uh
car there's a mechanic shop that we're
adding whistles to the mufflers so they
would make this insanely peter i need
you to pay attention i'm telling you
anyways that makes this like ear
piercing
noise with a muffler great so one of the
like car mechanics is like explaining
his reasoning because he's upsetting all
the neighborhood because he's like
he's like it's like an alarm clock
supposed to be making breakfast by then
the whistles go woohoo
so right here you should be shield
surfing okay
man
do i wish i had some stamina
we should have ridden
road ridden that ball
forget it
where am i going
we should fight the dragon which way am
i going oh i'm sorry
keep going you're good you're good i'm
gonna freeze to death
god the stamina thing okay so
keep going i'm trying to get the
i'm doing it
it's daytime in his video
[Laughter]
so
that's good
this this is not good this is this is
really not good i've been in good
situations they are nothing like this
yeah you're about to die
[Music]
yeah you are
you are my plebs ass put some clothes on
we
ride that ball we wish uh this is no we
don't know if this is gonna be a 24 hour
stream but uh
no
we're gonna we're gonna do this
yeah
yeah
okay can we figure out where he's going
because i feel like i cannot go up this
mountain
you ha no that's he's going that way
you honestly were on the right track
i figured the stamina thing so i should
be okay
now you got it now you're getting kid
these bats are
pretty fast aren't they
uh no you need it no now so you trade it
off now you got sprint now sprint
so release into it yeah so you yeah
ah
that's what happens when you change grip
on a controller
f
f by that i mean [ __ ]
uh should we trade back
all right boy see what you got
i am really failing out of this true not
even just failing like
very much failing
all right this is it this is the run
that doesn't make any sense really does
it describe it to me just grab it too
well
so i don't know
oh i don't have a paraglider you really
don't totally cool i knew that because
look at i got no fall damage on that one
don't
i don't know why you can't do it
you weren't you weren't really even
doing it
you take that [ __ ] back i'll do it right
now
i'm doing it right now legit
i don't even
i wasn't losing stamina i was doing this
and now no but you want you get you're
faster with stamina so i wasn't running
fine
is that what you wanted me to say yes
all right
see look at this he always gets his way
dude i'm telling you we can't go up this
mountain
certain doom
should we teleport we're gonna have to
teleport aren't we that might be yes
all right we'll switch right now
sorry link
f
here
sure yeah
look at that bat he thinks he got me
peace
just turn into a dungeon speedrun and
you can still get a world record that's
a pretty good point
just restart
man we've messed up on that shield it
was imperative
yep
uh
oh my god that movie just did oh
i can do that in my sleep
he just jumped off a tiny cliff
[Laughter]
but i see what you mean
okay wait maybe the beetle keep an eye
out yeah oh yeah
wait
where is that
[Laughter]
i it's gonna be 12 45 we're not gonna
have the paraglider we're not gonna have
the beetle and we're sure as hell not
gonna have a shield
not with that attitude
my father there's the beetle
i swear to god if you lose that beetle
you got it
oh yeah there's coffee
make a little potion bless you bless me
all right now we get the shield
we're going to 12 45 or maybe we're at
least doing oh
did he get these
he probably didn't get those
sorry old man we're speed running
making a great time pops
god help us
uh should i get the shield yeah
that sounds like a plan
and then we'll really get things moving
what
jelly why don't you go find yourself
some pb no
hey
this box oh is this yours
we got so stoked for something that he
accomplished in the first 10 seconds of
his playthrough
god dang it oh oh we need these yeah
um
about that shield
yeah yet you need to head back to where
the shield was no but he's gone but
maybe he's back
what the hell
oh that was
that was the first time i've opened that
let's just stare yeah don't give me i'm
trying to find a shield creep on these
sleeping book goblins that's not weird
and that's not a bad use of our time at
all
well then what should i do i would
really want that shield
we should eat
there's no time man
all right well so then
we're getting off the rails aren't we we
are
i think we should go back to that first
oh is that a shield in there or is that
just a bow
i think like see that little thing
nope that's a club
all right well let's just go for the
other shrine
okay 107 says forfeit and i say never
we got this
okay i'm currently doing other things
well that's that's rude
if anyone in chat knows where maybe
another shield is hit us up well i mean
we can at least get the hylian shield if
we really need to right
that's a pretty good point
once we get to our final destination
so rob how do you plan on getting up
there
you know peter i was kind of thinking
the exact same thing well
i'll use rivalli's gail nope can't uh
that guy keeps calling me
ravalli here
it's ready give me a call reservation
for two tomorrow night i hope you can
make it
lake i waited at the restaurant for four
hours late
your gail's ready but
you bailed
i feel like maybe
you're not committed to this friendship
here link you never call
all right
it's christopher walken dude there is a
shield the blue one has it what the blue
one oh back there the blue blue goblin
it's not that cold right here i don't
see any snow you're you're almost naked
actually i've heard that those the
underwear he's wearing is just painted
on it's one of those things
but it links into body paint yeah he
likes to he likes the feeling of just
the open air on his body dude without
his crying eyes looking at his wiener oh
damn
dude we're not gonna get up
i know
hmm
we're also running
can you carry a torch to make you feel
warmer
if i had a torch oh i have a little uh
bokoblin um bat that could work yeah and
there's a fire up there
okay well i don't even i don't even know
uh
okay well
i'm gonna die right now should i go warp
back somewhere else [ __ ] yeah um
is the best way to get there from the
second shrine
here or from yeah yeah but that's i got
nothing i got nothing on me i gotta i
know i'd eat that dooku stick if i could
but you can find some peppers we could
go back and get another beetle if you go
to the
what you can get
some yes you can get some peppers um on
the trail that's close to the shrine or
the shrine resurrection
there's like peppers that grow along the
path
up to the snow okay all right it sounds
like a plan
we are currently
uh we should be done with the game by
now
we're 44 minutes into our run
a lit torch does make you warmer
according to k supersonic one we
wouldn't be able to sprint
and make back all of our time
how much how much time do we have we can
beat this right no
we have 45 minutes we've currently made
10 minutes of progress into the speed
run
sounds like a challenge
so i think if you go right
left
okay now it's back to it it was back to
the left you make a right up on that
path
or is that that's into
this nope there's no pathway
but
oh baby
i got this
do i
yeah
yeah hmm
[Music]
i'm pretty happy i didn't take fall
damage there
oh god hell yeah this is sick
oh god is the path just around there
because you can
do you remember where it is
yeah
yeah it's this way
oh yeah now i remember
this is it
got some sticks
oh a couple of jerks
eating
snacking
fixing to
get them peps
okay is that shield
that
oh they're laughing huh
okay all right
okay
nice knowing you tuts
yeah tough decker suck it
go
oh did you get those peppers
uh
sure no
chili that's cool
later
catch y'all on the flip i got a speed
run
i'm a speed runner
that worked out oh we're dude we're set
look at all this pep
what they're still here
run run run run run
stop laughing
do the peppers keep you warmer [ __ ]
you might have to cook them into a dish
go go go go go go go go go go no i think
i still get the effect from it
oh no i didn't do it right now
well that's enough health to get me
there i think
i don't even want to look at chat right
now
you guys hate me i'm sorry
run felicia
all right so there's probably no way i
can climb this wall huh
oh
you got it yeah
okay
i'm sorry there's no timer we're just
gonna have to wing it
what are we at trust me the time time
the timer doesn't matter done
we are currently at 47 minutes oh
all right so we're just a tad behind him
uh-huh
just a bit a smidge
wow
yeah
i think we found our colleague i think
we found our oh look at this
all right [ __ ] up that excuse my
language
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bacon
making back those precious minutes
oh we'll see that's boulder in a sec
oh do we have to travel oh yeah oh yeah
that i can do skip skip shoot i just i
lost a couple seconds there
always be optimizing
uh yeah the peppers give you warmth but
i think you got to cook them that's true
what a doofus i was
skip skip oh wait yeah yeah back on
track
oh it's this one
yes get the stasis module
i don't need it
um
give me that hot goo
hot blue roon gu jesus christ what give
me that hot goo
that's why it's said in german i did not
take pity on your soul
god damn it
rob we are losing
we're losing viewers by the hundreds are
we oh yeah
they're just missing out
i'd say
oh he did the stasis there i kind of
blew it
up oh fly you fool
jesus
how did he do
haley gravali here maybe if you were my
friend more often i'd let you use my
power
oh well good luck
hey ravalli's back i remember earlier
when i said
all right should i try it
no but yeah
do you remember what to do
here i'm gonna play the
you got real close i'll be honest with
you
i think the problem is that you didn't
go off the exact
you need to go off like really at the
last second and at the apex
of your jump
use the power
the power
the the shield you know what i'm saying
okay
[Music]
one more time
for those of you that are sticking with
us thank you yeah thank you guys
in all seriousness and the from the
bottom of my heart my shield's gone
are you what kidding me
i think you gotta load an autosave
are we are we gonna give up our shield
what do you do are you sure it's gone
oh i just put it away i'm a freaking
idiot okay i'm like god dang it
i was waiting for you to open that
screen i was just making sure you uh
knew what was up oh
that old thing
oh
man all right one last time
thanks liam and thank you all for
yeah i know the stasis
[Laughter]
but
all right
this is it first try
all right one more time man be so cool
if i pulled it off like that guy
okay dokey
wait what this is
oh my god all right should i not do it
hey you should do it
well i didn't eat so i ran out of hearts
so i had to start from the beginning
kind of big
[Laughter]
i thought it was closer
it's okay
should you eat some food maybe just
you know food eat that beetle eat that
beetle no crunch it up
i
don't know about that
he was running though right he didn't
have his shield drawn before he did the
the jump
all right this is seriously gonna be the
last time i'm sorry okay
also we're ready yeah he was he was
sprinting
without the shield okay
wait
i got a brain fart i'm sorry i forgot i
was doing that it smelled in here can i
give it a shot
or no you want to give it one more try
one more try
yeah you know
okay
uh rock rough too cool
we uh we know we can move the rock we're
trying to speedrun the game using all
the hot strats
uh we're not giving up until we pull
them off eric green stop laughing at me
all right peter show us what you're made
of oh god
also uh you're
yeah eat that don't eat the beetle don't
don't why not
we've spent a lot of precious time
getting it you got to equip it oh what
the god damn it
not as hard as it looks huh
or easy that make any sense it is hard
forget it it is as hot as it looks why
isn't it equipped
okay if you don't do it this time we
have to start from the beginning of the
trying so that's fine oh thanks but we
have a lot of time to save
yeah okay
you could you yeah
you shield surfed in the end there you
bet i did
damn it
uh so
so uh if you're just joining us we uh
continue
we're
precious time
we're we're speed running this i just
if you're just joining what
we're actually doing pretty well if
you're just joining us uh we are at uh i
believe 15
minutes seconds actually seconds yeah we
did the glitch through the wall uh
backwards with the shield on your
forehead
um that's one of the new newer tricks
it's a rob smash
all right i say you just do stasis
okay 107 says eat the beetle do not
listen to him do not
no stop chat stop don't don't tell him
to
um okay this reminds me
[Laughter]
a little bit of raiders there huh why
didn't that one work for me
it wasn't uh the cooldown was still
still happening
i guess it was too hot shout out to all
the germans i like that there we go
was it too soon though no what are you
doing go
how can i sneak by it no you're going
live
dirty or
hurt all right uh you should probably
just take that
i i got a feeling we're gonna need that
later
for ganon
ganon
oh hot wow you're good this is hot hell
yeah
that thing took a trip
he probably got to cannon already
uh ben de ross said i'm on
your
left
peter is on the left
this is peter
you're losing time fought i thought
i was fought
tasha often okay um
rob what's my next move
surely i will have the hang glider and i
can just hang glide to gannon
you need to go back to the tower oh good
no you don't i no you go temple of time
okay so you do you gotta do the boulder
trick
ah
damn that's gonna be legit i just kind
of
i can't do it though yeah you can don't
how dare you i can do it
uh
let's see how
yeah the hammer is uh screwed at this
point
well he doesn't even use the hammer
well so he also uses a bomb
oh look at this jerk teasing you with a
glider whoa to go that way
no you're going no see there's temporary
no i know but did you see the way he did
it he hit one direction but put the bomb
on the other side of the rock so it
would go the opposite direction right oh
that actually i didn't even think about
it that way because it's it's precise
right you're not winging like you're
you're putting all the energy in first
he's good at this game
[Laughter]
[Music]
skip skip skip we're losing my friend i
am
pressing buttons there is nothing for me
to skip knox wants to know why it's in
german uh because i like it that way
uh
also though where is the time tempo of
time there put it put it there no put it
there
in there nope nope in there in there in
there yeah in there
it's not it's gonna
yeah yeah you know use a little feed
sees in there push that push that push
okay
all right all right
there we go there we go all right
that'll work how did he do it on the
first try he's i think he stood no you
uh
all right
he had it underneath the rock because
it's to to go up i think that's that's
key for that
that arc that
checked so in
rob i need the round one
he uses the square i don't care all
right
that's not gonna work
you can't get it donated
you don't donate me
super rude
yeah that's good yes nice
have you done this before
okay stasis it
gosh but then i need to start swinging
right
yeah yeah
let her rip wind it up get in there get
dirty
all right let's let's let's pause i
wouldn't do anything yet let's try this
all again
that's cool no we can't
oh right no we're doing this go load
back load back do it load back here
time warp there we're doing it
we have to do it time work back do it do
it do it
stop
start over
somebody reload the save yes no no don't
reload the safe just warp if you just uh
time travel okay okay okay time travel
what what
did i say time travel it's not time
travel kind of is time freezes
it's traveling
through some sort of time
if you're just joining us we're speed
running uh breath of the wild
um
we're doing pretty good we have uh i
think we're at like 10 minutes and 28
seconds record for the paraglider pretty
pretty good yeah
there's nobody i don't even just need to
say that we're confident it's just
self-evident at this point well as that
one guy in the chat
as the one guy in the chat said though
uh
there are two of us so we get to divide
by two because that makes complete sense
so let's see if it's six minutes
that's what
i'm sorry 28 minutes thank you i was
going to say 28. crazy
just do it
good line okay so nike all right do it
hold on just chill
because he's climbing i need him to not
climb
okay there we go so i need him to jump
he does it on the other side
no he doesn't that's fine
so it's like a real tiny hop okay god
this is difficult
okay okay
it's not that difficult
you didn't stasis
[Laughter]
i'm so swept up in the pressure rob do
it do it i wait no i need to go back to
the bomb
yeah but hit it yeah
[Laughter]
reload it we gotta try it we have to do
you want to do it sure
um
baby
that's such a cool line
which king hope
no king of nope
i really do need glasses what is a speed
run but a way to travel through time
isn't that cool
that's really cool
if only we could skip these cut scenes
then we'd actually be making progress
you know what you think only that old
man would just give us that freaking
paraglider
has he already i don't even remember no
we're about to get it
he's got telescopes oh right he's got to
tell a story because
he's been talking to no one all his life
all right here we go
all right
load it up hit it jump on it get down on
it
now
the jace
says he's gonna miss all the silly stuff
we'll be back
we'll be back we'll be back
we just i
like there was it two weeks ago we just
could not
think it was just we both were on the
same level like we have no other idea
because you know it has to be
entertaining right like we're not gonna
like just
we don't just wanna you know play the
game and accomplish sort of basic goals
we want to do it in
a way where our stupidity can flourish
right yeah yeah
exactly
which isn't difficult but
at the same time
oh link you look so tight get on get on
sorry for yelling i think you need to go
on to that you need to not be that far
around you need to be a little bit
closer to the bomb because that that
facet of the boulder seems to let you
hold on to it
okay
it takes two baby
oh it's stam is the stamina
stamina
that's why i couldn't get on doesn't
shut up josh
i'm beginning to like him less and less
have you noticed that joshua
kind of a jerk kind of a jerk
all right so hello
we're losing time peter we gotta oh we
gotta make up for how silly of me make
sure that you can at least get like find
a place where you can hop on this thing
oh that's why we have motion on this
yeah that's why
peter what's the german word from motion
[Music]
nicely done now
man should we reset this do it again no
okay so what were you saying
turn off your stasis
just figure out a place on the rock
where you can jump on it
and hold on
because no i'm
okay all right like that i take it back
like that i take it back
yes like that look like that that which
was so hard to accomplish on that piece
but a moment ago
ein halton on halton
i'd stayed at an anne
no
we're doing it no you're not oh you are
no you're not
oh wait i don't have uh
yeah okay let's try this uh
we have to we have to do it now we have
to do in order to make up the time we
lost
on our attempts to do it
oh
okay
time
we are an hour and five minutes into
this 41 minute speed run all right
okie dokie artichoke easy peasy
nope spin it up there we go watch out
for your stamina there's my boy
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man we lost so much time on that
game glitched out [ __ ]
bs what a load of crap where's the
temple
that was really great
[Laughter]
oh there's that whistle i just want to
hear it again
we're gonna get some morale back in our
lives
shorts nails yeah shorts
shirts
i like how there's a ladder here the
whole time that was a nice little
piece of info from the speed run
man a solid 500 people are watching this
you think the world would be interested
in our record
it's a record for something
hey old man
what you got
get me up here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boring boring
boring
we gotta go speed run speed run
all right what's next
uh okay
oh right we can't use any of these
amiibos that gadge was kind enough to
give us because we forgot to i forgot to
tie it into uh
and i couldn't
i kind of want to hear him say that in
german
and deutsche
that's all he's got um
all right so then you need to go to
karaoke village
no we don't yes we do
no we don't the quest is called
something impa dude we this is it next
ganon oh ganon yeah you're right what am
i talking about it's all right losing
sight of the prize
and the prize
whoops
swift's death is entering a cheat code
there this is going on we're on it we're
doing it no problem okay so next
oh my god there's not a chance and all
hell will be able to do it remember this
one or did you see this one no you
didn't i didn't show you it
dude
that was a whole lot of stuff that just
happened we need a horse
so peter the horse comes after this
right so he shoots it like over
that hill this is this is where it gets
weird can you cut okay yeah i'll go back
okay so he
staces it we're pretty good at that we
got that down go back no you missed it
trust me there's something no no no no
no no no i didn't miss it
look what he does
dude played at like
half speed yeah so he uh
well
okay so he freezes that one gets it all
juiced up look yeah juices it up look
what he does
what are you doing next oh you just wait
this is gonna be
legit
easy to pull off he does okay he does a
backflip sorry guys hang in there chat
he does a
back flip
what yeah we're gonna do it
oh he does a back flip and then like
it like kicks him i i think the purpose
of it is to
not miminize jesus you get it miminize
jesus
i think he's trying to create a little
bit of momentum with the backflip so
that when it launches it like so it like
hits him he's already mid-air when the
rock launches it then picks him up with
it
you know what i mean oh he times the
stasis yeah oh god damn it it's
fine okay let's imagine if you pull it
off
he just likes to say mississippi
okay
so what are you gonna do it on
i think that was eleven
uh well what is it you do you know you
said like eight
i think you said like eight
do i know i mean you just listen for the
sound
all right all right blow it up oh wait
that's cool we got another one
i say you just do it the traditional way
this is not traditional this how we play
this game
to hell with tradition devise
defies all logic oh don't go anywhere
name it
okay
yeah all right last time
okay anything about this um
dejected moss says keep your day jobs
this is our day job
on the contrary
thanks for your support that didn't work
out i did that wrong let's try it again
how i did the bomb first it's gonna go
oh [ __ ] hop on
wow seconds
whoa hey guys look at that
and a kill
we're gonna need that
[Laughter]
oh yeah
i'm surprised we haven't been worse
about the german
yeah
um a real friendly people but a language
i'll never stop laughing at yeah it's
pretty interesting it's actually like
in many ways very similar to english
yeah
yeah
um
all right well this will cost us some
time
but
that's cool
because
you want it oh
opponent we don't need no stinking a
pona
paris eagle
f
some hero
you use this new hot stealth jump trick
i learned
gotcha
all right moment of truth ganon here we
come zelda we're coming
she can't hear you
she keep oh
i can hear her
that's all those mushrooms you've been
eating
it is 420 but that's hot so it doesn't
make any sense yeah
is there a mushroom
holiday
truman uh i'm sure in some country
that'd be a very dangerous day
i feel like
or maybe the least dangerous day
oh he was doing this other trick watch
what he did i don't even get it but he's
like using his arrow which we don't have
so forget at all
he pulls out basically pulls out his bow
and he like gets off and gets back on
his horse you'll see him like spin
around it's
neat oh yeah i don't i don't understand
any of that you you're we're even
watching it at 0.5 speed and doesn't
make any sense to me
shut up course
uh bob jones we don't have amiibo
abilities because we oh and we're
already in the thick of it well that's
fine well maybe move
good job
oh he's quick huh
he's a quick one
that was so dumb rob we got 15 minutes
left to beat this game can we do it i
think so i think i know he does it in
what how many how long does it take him
to be gannon 15 minutes so we're
actually pretty close we'll do it in
seven
down deal oh you wanna play
i guess
no time like the the present
i bestow you the speed running
controller it's a little
damp because it's so intense
if you just
go go go go i need to go this way the
right or is that the empty quest go to
cannon go to gas just chill oh my god
well actually you could set it to gannon
i think that's true you just picked the
main quest yeah oh don't
bear with me i i haven't played zelda in
a while sorry
that's right you don't like horses many
people say that that
they don't like horses they don't like
horse in the game right
it makes sense i don't know you you use
it very like maybe around hyrule and
that's about it uh you just can't really
use it anywhere else huh
um
why the german language well because uh
we're
really trying to save precious time yeah
uh every moment counts and apparently
the
german
language
feature settings
language language language speeds up
oops scroll time on dialogue
so
we need that
i wonder how much traffic we're gonna
get off this from people who think we're
actually capable of speed running this
game
[Laughter]
well it is called the speed run special
right
so
we should have put speed running quotes
that guardian up there
oh boy
it's just a turret
it's got no legs
you ain't got no legs
guardian
all right you want to go so he goes this
way so next is you want to go to the
center of uh hyrule town
where where there is uh hello
oh
mama planned it don't even worry about
it
i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm
good i'm good your horse is on fire
i'm on fire oh like in the sense that
i'm doing really well
[Music]
that was a really
that was a really sad death noise
oh they're fighting oh yeah oh great
call
oh now we're good now you're good
no you're good you could probably eat a
little bit if you have anything
oh
[Music]
peter
and there you go
you can usually keep going you're just
warming up yeah so again uh the plus
side to having two people uh for the
speed run is that we can divide by two
uh so that's gonna be our time yeah even
if we don't beat the game
i guess
yeah buddy
man when we kill ganon
[Laughter]
we get this guy and oh link
we could go to one
there's a lot of things we could do
oh
look at this look at what hard right
you've done hard right
or are you you know you do what you want
dude this horse does not want to listen
because your your bond with him is weak
i'll bond with him when there's time to
bond
dart right cat's in the cradle in the
silver
is that your speed run music right right
because i don't have time to bond with
my horse but then by the time i get old
he won't have time to bond with me
did you see the guardian did you see
god i i see him you talk about music you
don't know what cat stevens you know his
lyrics mean right hard right where into
the guardian
right when he bought he's about to fire
god
i can't what do you mean hard right
that doesn't work with a horse that
doesn't care
oh
no
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm giving you a hard time
you just keep yelling hard right
i pressed the button
you son of a [ __ ] you
dude like if i had to say anything i
think you have been sacrificing a lot of
time by not speeding up these menus
so i think like
kind of
you know get better about that well i
mean i don't know
oh you're saying it's my fault
i'm saying
saying you kind of ruined this i can't
make a hard right i know that's what
you're thinking in your brain but i
can't do it
god
i know
maybe this is why
we need an opponent
we have the amiibo i want you to do this
okay because i'm tired
okay
all right
big guns
coming out
oh dapper says world record slow run
thank you
wait a minute
we're coming zelda golden nugget says
golden
nuggets ganon oh yeah
tell him hard right rob
hard right rob
oh wow this horse really is not
responsive is he
okay just warming up getting back to the
controls
retuning the synapses
tune it up
death nine bob you're counting thank you
i can't beat that
i don't really i don't think it's nine
it's more like two yeah
that's what i'm saying
okay
let's not be unreasonable
let me enter the code
[Laughter]
all right take it easy baby
dude i dare you oh
this is good enough for me
all right next stop next up on the list
is uh we gotta find uh
where's that statue i am out of stamina
is this guy advancing kind of
haha missed
oh there it is
so here we should find a shield and a
sword
uh royal guards stuff
oh just just
look at that okay oh no nights
oh you know what well forget it
we do need a we need we don't need the
horse we just run
a horse is a horse
but of course of course
pro tip don't die
man his feet would look
real gross like it'd just be
bone
was it you and i who are making that
joke like he gets the zelda oh yeah
[Laughter]
my love
[Laughter]
all right
so here
i'm more bone than man
aren't you happy
nailed
all it let's get some of that time back
with this
run
making back all that time
sweet time come on come on
do it i dare you do it do it do it
dude flirting with death
owning it
get in that door
do whatever you want i don't care
anymore
all right so uh cool all right
you did it get down
and gannon should be right up these
stairs i don't have a boat
um you can throw your items
okay you can throw that beetle okay
all right
what does he use here
um
bow and arrow also do we got any any
food just that beetle oh we got some
this is this is enough in die hand well
i guess the one cool thing is you know
it doesn't really matter if we have food
or not right because it's just one hit
you know we're done so that's the plus i
guess yes
look at this jackass doesn't look
difficult what how do you oh no
he's a quick one
uh can you stasis him
no i can't it's not upgraded
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah
that should have dropped his shield that
didn't work out
on griff ungriff yeah i'm griff
doing just no damage yeah we gotta go
we'll come back we'll just come back
time
that's going to set us back a little bit
peter we are an hour and 23 minutes into
our
speed run
this is the fastest i've ever done it
can you see me now no oh okay
yeah get in that position
is he getting up
i don't know
okay so then he does this he throws this
bomb there that worked out and then i
hide
oh yes he doesn't see me oh but he's
gonna hear me in a second what a doofus
oh god
maybe use a different weapon that's
stronger
i'm just saying
yeah
you did it
sorry i
golfo's porn okay oh i'm losing time i
didn't need all that stuff
schwann's response but i need that he
uses this
uh
dude
okay
the more i the more i realize is that we
need a bow oh we can get one later on
yeah yeah but we can't cook that beetle
hmm hmm that's going to be a deal
breaker why not
oh i can use bat duh duh good call duh
good call your smart let's
go all right let's cook baby
in die hand
all of it yeah just everything
well
level one stimulant how did he get three
what else did he cook
oh did i not cook this tooth is that it
the sporn the spawn
oh
i think you're supposed to stand next to
it and blow yourself
oh carolyn says we're losing time
that's cool ancient arrows
i know what it's like
until i feel
fine
time
so he says screw you guys and this guy's
not supposed to know him here
oh
block hit him in the dick oh
the dick
i'm sure he's got one is that a weak i i
never knew
never knew that was a noon i never knew
that was a weak spot
[Music]
okay
oh
it's
i mean we're we're one minute
wait wait
dang that's gonna cost us like five
seconds
[Laughter]
it's so much more fun sucking at a game
when you have someone else who sucks
next to you oh can you imagine if i if i
did this by myself it probably would
have a mental breakdown and you would
never see me ever again
holy [ __ ] you did it
remember what i taught you
am i doing any damage
oh no these guys
dying bug stock
is [ __ ] broken
uh reset
redo
no
god
grab the thing blow him up and enter the
code
do what grab the explosives
blow them up not how he did it though it
all right
let's just do whatever you want chart
your own course follow your own heart
peek-a-boo how you like that boys
have another hungry
do you know what pizza is in german what
flamenco
now i'm hungry
translates to flame cake
that's pretty neat yeah
it's my only neat fact
uh
so we're now nearing the question oh god
dang this save huh
guys tell me about it
uh so you got some long weapons down
there you could poke at them with wait
or you could
call a horse that we don't have
i would i would grab the
this is why hunter yeah
okay
look at i don't know where i'm here wait
wait wait don't jump they don't know
that you're here
for that half second
pizza is a vegetable that's pretty neat
i did not know that bruh
okay let's do
[Music]
okay all right
okay all right okay stop
okay here we go uh what do you want to
do with oh wait i forgot about this guy
rob what are we doing i don't know no
i'm sorry i'm spacing out i'm losing
time let me let me let me fail that
sounds great
because this brain is running on fumes
now
despite my my uh insider speedrunning
trick of having a hearty breakfast
which consists of
uh i had half a thing of naked green
machine juice
so you had sugar
i'm not done wait
uh bacon egg
i didn't know you had a speech
impediment
i definitely do
oh
you want to set that thing up
oh you're right
yeah you're right
i kind of feel like you should run back
and uh approach it like
when they don't see you like like how he
does it let's just do how he was doing
it
sorry i'm having a jim halpert moment
with the camera while you talk
oh is that oh you're the gym in this
situation huh
all right it's 12 47. uh let's go to one
let's just go to one and we'll be done
by then
yeah we'll probably have them
we'll have them look at that stance
that's pretty that's pretty neat that
also
makes my hamstring sore just thinking
about it
oh yeah i don't i really don't i think
you got the approach here
i mean you don't necessarily need to
kill these guys right but you want maybe
you need his weapon maybe i want his
blood
okay
sorry i'm a sick individual
that's your next move here
oh that's cool
thanks thought of it myself
wow he totally
did that jump jump jump nice
give me your here it comes
richter
heck yeah dude
nice tasha often okay
uh
yeah
so what do you want me to do
uh okay oh next i know what's next okay
um
okay look uh to the left
well i'm just getting my sweet
moblin horn we don't need any of that
uh
he goes up he goes up this
he jumps he like
comes right up
he jumps straight up there's just no go
back
oh i'm gonna ditch a crappy weapon
so i got someone you can't i got some
unfortunate news uh i think i saw scott
in the chat saying that he needs you to
okay one of his reviews
that should we just keep going
scott
just keep going you're trying to
interrupt a world record speed run yeah
my god okay
uh left go back
up there up there see the statues climb
up the wall behind the statues and then
he jumps yeah there you go perf
now you're getting one more
scott we both know your reviews are good
enough
yeah that's true
okay so to save time here peter just get
that bow i just smash that
we're gonna save like a couple seconds
perfect yeah now we got bombs seems
perfect kind of
i'm again i'm running on fuel
this speed run has done a number uh
okay i forget what's next
oh uh
yeah straight away so uh
oh whoa whoa
wait
yeah that's
oh no it's uh down downstairs is a
doorway
back to where we were all the way down
back to where you were yeah
isn't there
oh nice crap did we get an auto
maybe we should call it you want to call
it
what are we going to do
i kind of want to
go to like
the footsteps of gannon
get a hidden or two
all right should we just do one more
yeah you know i think scott's all talk
because i'm looking at my email
i don't see his review oh snap
i'm calling you out
um
okay so why don't we do one more death
then
[Music]
you're not thinking about that door
i don't think you can get in that door
you can't just blow stuff up no it's not
it looks like a real stupid door anyway
yeah
i mean it's stupid it doesn't even work
you know
yeah i know doors
that's no door he went up here
does he have to climb
backwards
[Music]
perfect
i think he just goes this way
oh bingo ah
oh great there's a great man once said
bingo was his name-o
e-i-e-i-e-i-o
oh crap oh crap
oh don't you dare don't you dare peter
we ain't done yet
this is it
oh i didn't do it oh nope
this guy needs to chill out
you should try you should try to kill
him
[Music]
uh rob is that gonna do it yeah we
should just kill it
hey peter
that was a good high five and uh we did
it great run great run
well that was fun thank you guys so much
for uh putting up with that yeah
uh i hope this has been fun i hope
you've enjoyed triforce over the past
five weeks
four or five weeks yeah
uh yeah it's been fun we have some good
times i'm gonna uh definitely compile
all of the episodes we've done and do a
little highlight reel so stay tuned for
that um
hopefully i can have that for the
weekend but we'll see i've got some
other things in the works here
um
but
this won't be the definite end i think
we might come back and do you know
definitely the dlc down the road which
is post summer definitely yeah we'll
come back for that definitely yeah but
uh you know if you've got any ideas i'm
still gonna check out the comments on
youtube uh and such and you know we have
incorporated them in the past into doing
bits like one of us is blindfolded
directing the other one that was a good
dandel time wearing that
hat behind us that i made in 10 minutes
um
but yeah
there's been triforce thanks for joining
us guys stay tuned we will return at
some point in the future have a good one
see you guys happy 4 20.
you